you
yo receive I'll auntie sia y me da Mao
muy profundo meta carazzo yo sentía
mucho inclus otro a lo siento por
newcomen auntie
[Music]
when I went to zimbra Daniel you are
impotent internal pie yo creo que su
serva into a la went to Ghana falando
aqui y me donde me inclusion hago la
Serna versa na ho k criollo ella en lo
de la fere y estrella gr ND trudeau
intrude olsommer essa as leader the
Cuban Revolution he means the world to
Cubans in my opinion from what I've
experienced what I've learned from
Cubans that I've met in form
relationships with um he's like a father
suppose people
[Music]
you
from Cuba I live in west palm beach and
I came down with the trunk drug and we
wanted to celebrate what happened to you
hoping the waiting for a long time I
became a citizen this year and I came
from few by 1980 in
doubled only 11
my family brought me here on leaving
Cuba
what's funny and when I opened as far
three years ago we found a little coffin
but a wooden coffin somebody how does an
ornament from halloween and we put
Fidel's name on it and we said one day
when he dies we're gonna bury it so I
guess today's a day
[Music]